all right there's only one thing that
can get me up bright and early
ish on this what day is it
on this day i said bright and early-ish
takes time to make this video and that's
joker pictures we have new joker
pictures well new pictures
same joker yet different joker the same
joker long story short jared leto's
joker is going to be
in the snyder cut i know it's called
zack snyder's justice league but i'll
just always call it the snyder cut
you did this internet you did this and
now we have pictures of him love the
hair
man it's like long-haired joker that's
joker forever now he just always has
long hair there was one live-action
short-haired joker in the past
decade and that was the one people
didn't like and they were like all right
you can come back
but you have long hair although i think
that was his call he's probably like
i'll come back i'm not cutting the hair
again though point is i like the fact
that zack snyder's throwing him this
bone because it shows that
even he wants redemption for jared
leto's joker i think we all
did at a point you know i mean if you've
ever humored the idea
that jared leto's joker was actually
jason todd that's just the bargaining
phase of acceptance which means you
wanted it to
we all did no one wants this joker that
just kind of stands out as the one
that's not good
we all want it to fit and make sense
zack snyder's like all right we'll just
i'll bring him back we'll have a
completely different vibe and
maybe it'll work jared leto's a good
pick for a joker he's a good casting for
a joker i just don't think we got to see
that that's neat that they're throwing a
mulligan
in hollywood the land of zero second
first chances i mean no pressure jared
leto i'm just saying
you picked the most fickle industry to
work with ever so the fact
that a second chance is even happening
is baffling lightning striking twice
just
doesn't quite cover it but okay let's go
over the look long hair check tattoos
gone at least the forehead tattoo the
damage tattoo
that's gone looks like his tattoos are
gone along with the pride of anybody
who got jared leto joker tattoos
emulating his tattoos
yeah that's gone too yes the validity of
your permanent life decision
has been retconned officially hey it
happens i've already seen the jokes
though
the jokes are already rolling in and
funny thing is i don't disagree with
them so i'm saying he looks like
leatherface's emo younger brother he
looks like rob zombie's michael myers
looks like eric draven from the crow
though heath ledger's joker also got
crow jokes so that's not new personally
what i thought of i thought he looked
like a marilyn manson album cover
couldn't you see that
call it biomechanical animals point is
though those jokes those comparisons
they're still on the spectrum of horror
and i'll totally take that looking
horror movie enough for people to make
jokes and comparisons about it
to me is better than looking like a
surge energy drink hit the tgri
ooze and became a person thus far this
has all been chatter about the character
design but what is the performance
because you know the tattoos the energy
drink persona that's just
one part of the jared leto joker thing
that didn't vibe with fans but his
performance came across as like he was
trying to do a heath ledger joker but
didn't want to
fully emulate the heath ledger joker
so it was like a bad heath ledger joker
impersonation i mean you can have the
look all you want but if you don't have
the personality to match it
what good is it performance is gonna be
a big part of this one you know just
like if we're still on
the horror movie comparison michael
myers og terrifying horror movie stalker
he has the look but if he comes on
screen like
[Music]
yeah that'll kind of kill the vibe so
we're just getting a peek into the jared
leto joker persona by
seeing the character but we don't know
what his acting is gonna be
and from this glimpse a glimpse like
this you know a photo release
like this is essentially the studio or
the director being like hey
here's a glimpse of what i'm promising i
don't think his performance from suicide
squad
would necessarily match this vibe so i
think that's going to be different as
well because if for nothing else
we're going to have to fix the laugh i
can't think of this dude like
[Music]
i'm not supposed to keep it he probably
shouldn't though
and i've gone on and on about horror
movie stuff because it's fun theorizing
and speculating about joker for me he
also looks like he's been cutting up
bodies
so i think that's pretty cool and i
think that matches a horror movie vibe
and the comparisons people have given
him but i also think joker lends himself
to horror a couple of good graphic
novels i can point to are death of the
family and end game both by scott snyder
not related to zack snyder but if you
look at death of the family in end game
two great joker stories
also had horror story elements in it but
they're not horror comics so that's what
i mean when i say
horror elements and he looks like he
could be horror element joker i'm seeing
it
in that kind of spectrum which could be
as accurate as
speculation from one picture ever is so
we'll see but i am
optimistic because i do think the
picture itself is a solid departure from
the jared leto joker that we got before
in suicide squad in the end it's all
about execution we'll see where it goes
i don't really think he's going to be a
huge part of justice league because
he was an afterthought probably just a
couple scenes where someone talks to him
like
joker well wait no it's uh it's ben
affleck joker
do you know anything about darkseid i
don't know why he would but
here we are talking just imagine that
world though if he sticks with it and
fans end up loving his portrayal of
joker
that's got to be one of the biggest
redemption arcs
ever all right so the new look of jared
leto's joker in the snyder cut
i won't ask if you've seen it because
you have spent in this video but what do
you think about it whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
oh